[Music]
okay joining me on the freedom pack
podcast today is political commentator
and host of the david pakman show david
pakman david welcome to the freedom pact
thank you for inviting me
it's my pleasure sir and
this is primarily a personal development
podcast so
i wanted to just start this off with
your own personal journey before we get
into any of the the topics that were
requested
so
would you remember a significant point
in your life because out of all the
political commentators i've spoken to
there seems to be a moment in time they
can reflect back on with our switch
flipped and they became interested in
politics do you remember that time for
yourself
no really no because i just grew up
around politics it was always i'm i'm
from argentina and in argentina you know
politics is one of the main
uh driving forces of discussion at any
kind of friendly or family gathering so
it was always kind of in the ether so to
speak
uh but i do think that the 2000
presidential election
the results of which were not known for
some time because of the the um
uh involvement of the supreme court as a
result of what happened in florida with
bush v gore i i remember that being a
moment where
i had sort of followed the election from
day one and
was more closely involved i would say
i read an interview with yourself online
where you said that you always knew that
you wanted to go down the sort of
entrepreneurial route or
you know being your own boss what was it
about that lifestyle that you gravitated
towards so much
well it was more what repelled me from
the alternative and you know i worked a
number of jobs growing up and
i never liked um i never liked having a
boss i never liked having a set schedule
i didn't like
most corporate culture and a lot of this
was before the kind of modern
tech companies where maybe i would like
the culture more i don't know i've never
tried it fortunately and maybe i'll be
lucky enough never to have to
uh but it was really about as i started
doing this and realizing that this felt
like a way to much more directly
determine my fate and determine what my
days would look like and it doesn't mean
it was less work in fact i would argue
it's more i mean i've never really done
working in the sense that
if the website breaks whenever or if
whatever happens
i'm sort of always on in a sense that's
the downside to it
but the upsides are so significant for
me
that at this point i i consider myself
almost broken in terms of being able to
work like a normal job i don't think i
could do the thing where you know david
we start at 9 15 here and i noticed that
it was 9 45 when you got here and i i i
really would would have a difficult time
with that and i get that it's very
privileged and i'm not fortunate to be
able to be in that position today
yeah i think most entrepreneurs i speak
to they talk about that sort of five for
two trade off where people give five
days of their life to uh to build in
someone else's dream to then get
two days back on the weekend where they
can actually enjoy it
and you know there's that old saying
that if you love what you do you'll
never really work a day in your life
is your monday to friday
a similar feeling to your saturday and
sunday
no it's really not i mean one of the
things that i've noticed early was that
this world of news and politics
particularly when it's so online based
and the platforms that i publish my
content to it's one of the most toxic
things i can imagine for sort of like uh
um
someone living in a developed country
right i mean i'm not saying that this is
like uh hunger not having enough to eat
or anything like that i'm not
suggesting that but in terms of the
culture
some of the most toxic cultural stuff is
following news and politics particularly
through an online space so we condense
our five episodes into four days a week
of filming and i'd really try to
completely tune out as much as possible
news and politics for close to three
full days a week now as we get closer to
elections it's not really practical and
there's more and more weekend rallies
and things like this but i try to create
a good line between my my working days
and my my off days doesn't mean i'm not
doing work but it's more business
strategy and and accounting type stuff
than it is the news and politics
yeah that's really interesting because
i'm certainly no political commentator i
have a
you know an interest in politics maybe
you could say that but certainly not you
know an intense interest and i remember
there was a brief period of time where i
you know i was i was watching all these
political commentators trying to take in
as much info from all over the spectrum
as i could
and i remember i probably spent about
three weeks where i would you know tune
into these programs every day and by the
end of the three weeks i remember
thinking i can't digest any of this
stuff anymore it's dragging me down so
how do you combat that sort of political
burnout that you get when you're just
always looking at news and and different
perspectives it is quite draining i
found
i would say three things i mean one is
what i already mentioned which is this
should be
something you're deliberately taking
time off from so that would be the first
thing i would say the second thing would
be
i would really try to skew my focus
towards things where i might be able to
have an impact or do something because
feeling like you can't you know one of
the things in jobs that seems to make
people have low job satisfaction is
feeling like you have no control over
the circumstances and i would apply the
same idea to the news that we consume so
whether that means focusing locally or
focusing on a particular issue that you
might be able to do something about i
think that that's an important thing
and then number three it's it's also
filling your life with other things
altogether um that
that don't relate to the news and
politics of the day
yeah
so if you google yourself it comes up
david parkman progressive political
commentator and i think that's a word
that probably means different things to
different people what does the word
progressive mean to david pakman
quite simply if the question is what is
the political ideology that's associated
with that term it's really uh for me
like social democracy the northern
european sort of model where we're
talking about a capitalist system we're
still talking about markets at least in
theory being able to direct resources in
most but not all areas you know i would
choose some areas and take them out of
that health care for example public
education uh police and fire etc
but for the most part we're talking
about a well-regulated capitalist system
that says we want to allow
people's ingenuity and creativity and
entrepreneurship to
uh benefit them but at the very very top
we want to use taxation to ensure that
also at the very bottom no one falls
below a certain standard of living that
we can easily guarantee right now for me
that's that's the very very general
perspective
yeah and
so i i mentioned i've spoke i've spoken
to a number of political commentators
this isn't a political show but i i just
so happen to have those conversations
and
i personally when i i don't do so much
of these conversations anymore but when
i was i i tried my best to try and speak
to those across the spectrum i didn't
want to just go down one route i wanted
to try and take in as much perspective
and and information as i could
um
and i found that
you know if i was speaking to
someone with a you know a certain
ideology that
i would get comments from some people
saying how could you speak to that
person how could you give them a
platform they this they then even though
i didn't agree with
uh explicitly say i agreed with anything
they said
then sort of i was
tarnished with the same brush and
so my question to you would be do you
think it's important to speak to people
from
all over the spectrum
if possible or do you think
someone like myself and you can be
honest that i have a
bigger responsibility to monitor the
conversations i'm having where do you
sit on that
well generally speaking
you know it's very easy to say hey uh
diversity of opinions and uh talking to
different people is good you know it's
very easy it's it's almost meaningless
because very few people would say no you
should only speak to people who only
have your existing ideas of course that
that's that's a great thing
i think you know the term i generally
apply to this is responsible platforming
and so when i do an interview with an
extremist of some kind you know i've
interviewed white nationalists and
homophobes and the whole thing
my approach is sort of twofold the first
is are there ideas
catching on enough that they're worth
refuting and challenging because i don't
find particular value in finding some
completely obscure you know imagine a
conspiracy theorist whose conspiracy is
just to pick something that there's an
invisible
weightless
purple elephant
in every grocery store
there's no point that that's not really
interesting to me that's not a movement
that's building behind it fine you know
that that i would ignore but if there's
a movement that
is gaining some traction
i want to first say well
should it be refuted or at least
challenged and the second part is am i
equipped to actually do it because what
i don't want to do is provide
sort of a free platform for
propagandizing
now sometimes the technique is to give
people the rope with which to hang
themselves that's a decision that's made
in individual conversations but i want
to be able to responsibly platform these
people early on i would sometimes get
disagreement in my audience why did you
give this person a platform and the idea
was well these ideas are getting enough
attention that i think they're worth
refuting so generally speaking great
conversation that's fantastic
do it responsibly make sure you're
equipped to do it and the last part i
would put uh the last piece of this that
that i might add is it's okay to find
some folks that are so far gone that
it's not actually worth engaging with
them i think that that's okay that that
can be a realistic thing at a certain
point great we've heard the theory that
donald trump actually won the election
when he lost we've heard 50 different
arguments which conflict among
themselves and could you know i think
we kind of get it how much more of that
are we really going to do i think it's
okay at a certain point to say we're
moving on to other things
i think this is a question that's going
to have you know a different answer for
everybody and so rightly so
but
are you the type of person where
your friends tend to
align with your beliefs and ideologies
or do you maybe have friends from across
the political spectrum
well there's a couple of answers to that
i mean if we're talking about my closest
friends it's it's people i grew up with
and you know
i grew up in massachusetts and then
moved to new york city which are liberal
right so just by virtue of geography
i'm a la around a lot of left-wing
people so
in a sense there's definitely a skew
there i don't my friends are not 50 50
right wingers and left wingers within
that though there's definitely a variety
of opinions i have you know very
anti-firearm
friends
and many friends who are firearms owners
for example or i have friends who differ
as to what level of taxation they think
is appropriate what i don't have is sort
of virulently
homophobic transphobic anti-semitic
friends because that that to me feels
sort of over a certain line where
there's probably not a cultural fit here
in in many ways
something interesting i saw a couple
weeks back um these conversations
difference in an opinion i i saw your
appearance on trigonometry
and um in a i think was called a good
faith discussion
and then a couple of days later i saw um
i think you made a video and then the
trigonometry guys made a reaction video
what sort of happened there was there
was there a disconnect what sort of
broke down
i i don't know um my uh i don't know
what their video said i haven't seen
their video i'm aware they made one but
i just have there's so many reaction
videos done to my content that i can't
watch all of them so i'm guessing
from what i saw on twitter i guess they
felt that me saying that they were right
wingers in the title of my video was a
smear now
i don't use right winger as a smear my
understanding was that they were right
wingers my experience was that in the
moments before our interview they said
we're right wing but we're not
right-wing nuts
and then after the fact i guess one or
both of them said they're actually
centrists or something i i don't know
but i'm to my my understanding having
just seen two tweets was that they felt
the use of the term right winger was a
smear and inaccurate but beyond that i'm
not really sure
what would your advice be to to people
out there
about to engage in a
debate or discussion with someone who
has
very different beliefs to themselves do
you think there are any you know values
or things that people should be mindful
of when having those conversations
well i think it's important to
understand
not ideally going in you would know not
only what are the beliefs of the people
you're going to be talking to but why do
they believe those things so if you were
going into a debate about health care
for example and you know you're going to
be debating someone who's against uh
government involvement in health care it
would be good to know why they're
against it you know they believe that
government doesn't do things well for
example or that it's communist and
socialist which it's of course it's not
but it would be good to know whether
that's their belief i think that that's
important i mean it's similar to when i
host some kind of extremist on my show i
want to have a sense of what are their
beliefs i do also think it's you know
not not in the sense of tone policing
but it might be good to know whether
there are certain words or phrases that
might uh
be triggering to to the people you're
talking to i found out this happened a
very long time ago but in some kind of
uh discussion i don't remember the
details exactly but with a discussion
with some religious right person
um i
referred to
what i now understand is the belief of a
certain wafer being the literal body of
christ as a cracker
you know like in the u.s we call these
these are you know crackers sort of uh i
don't know if it's the same the same
word everywhere but it's a piece of food
you know a wafer of sorts or yeah and i
later was told that it's
for people who believe that's literally
the body of their god that it's
offensive to call it a cracker and so i
didn't know that at the time to me it
was like that's a it looks like a
cracker to me i see people eating a
cracker and and so it wasn't that i
it's not that it changes my belief in
the underlying thing but it's useful to
know whether such a phrase might be
triggering to the person you're talking
to
yeah this this sort of political divide
between people and i i may not be right
here again i'm not too into this space
as yourself but
from over here in in the uk um yeah
there is a political divide but i i feel
as though it may not be as tribal as it
seems in the us it seems
very tribal in in that it seems to be a
maybe more so from one side than the
other but a lack of
desire to debate or have a civilized
discussion it's almost
you know that side is
you know
if that makes sense that they
what's the word i may be looking for
here it seems to be quite a black and
white almost right and wrong and the
left and the right seem to be
at an almost an internal conflict which
i don't really see that happening in the
uk as much
my question would be why is america
so divided
well unfortunately
if you ask 10 different people you'll
get 10 dramatically different answers to
that question i think there's a number
of answers and some of them are not
particularly
palatable to lots of folks like one of
the things i said on the trigonometry
interview was that we do have a problem
in the united states
where a lot of people i believe on the
american right as a result of
believing that
education is a form of liberal
indoctrination
being distrustful of empiricism science
teachers etc
are quite literally less educated on the
facts and when you don't have a shared
understanding of what the basic facts
are we can come to different conclusions
we can layer different morality on top
of the facts but if we can't even agree
on very basic facts it's really
difficult to have a useful conversation
i'm talking really simple things like do
vaccines cause autism
um who won the election in 2020
uh really just simp you know simple
stuff when you lack that shared
understanding
it's hard to have the good faith
conversations where i do think in other
countries there is some not in every
country i mean in argentina there's a
lot of lack of factual basis as well but
when you at least start with an
understanding of of the factual basis
the disagreements become much more
productive in my mind so i think that's
one aspect and it has to do with lack of
funding for education the republican
party doesn't really like public
education some want to eliminate the
department of education go in the
charter and private and homeschooling
model this stuff has a real impact so
that's kind of like one piece
the media environment is very very
disturbed
from the standpoint of uh online news
algorithms amplification of of of uh
untrue reports and conspiratorial
reporting i think that's a big part of
it as well but then also kind of less
part in
everything i've said so far many will
say that's incredibly partisan david
and it isn't because i think that the
split is quite partisan we also have
such a large country with such cultural
different differences i not long ago
spent time in rural northern indiana
which for people not in the us may or
may not know is a very conservative area
and it is a very rural area and all you
really have in terms of community
centers are
gun ranges
and evangelic evangelical churches
it makes sense that if that's your
environment for your first 18 years you
will have a very different perspective
when you are old enough to vote than
someone who grows up in san francisco
for example so that's more of a
geographic reality and i could go on i
mean there's so many different things
happening
yeah it was interesting you said about
who is the president i saw a
clip on your instagram the other day
where i can't remember the gentleman's
name but you asked him who won the
presidential election he said well it's
a it's a tricky question or it's a funny
question
yes yeah yeah i mean that how how are we
going to really have a conversa how are
we going to solve any problems when that
is not even something we can all agree
like okay joe biden won and you might
not like it it's okay
but that's the person that won it's very
hard to have a conversation
what needs to happen for sort of america
to
to pull back and this divide maybe to
get a little bit closer
i don't know you know there's lots of of
contingents that will give you a very
simple answer like for example
there are some now on the right who are
saying the solution to just about every
problem they see the fact that abortion
is legal as a problem they see the fact
that there are mass shootings as a
problem which so do i but they will say
the solution to all of these problems is
you need more god you need more faith
religious faith you need prayer in
school that they say that's the solution
i don't think that that's the solution
um in fact you look at other countries
that don't have a lot of the problems we
have
they have much lower belief in god so it
seems like there's a very clear
counterfactual there um
i i do think that i mean this is maybe a
little too narrow for our conversation
but i think that not just education but
really specifically we should be
teaching critical thinking and media
literacy starting somewhere between age
10 and 12 in every school
and there are lots of people on the
political right who have fought that
they call it a form of indoctrination by
the left i call it the tools to think
for oneself
and i believe that if we did that i mean
it would take a generation right that's
the problem it takes a while for this
stuff to have an impact
a lot of these problems would sort
themselves out and that people would
never fall for many of the things they
they fall for today
so going back to maybe something we
touched on earlier um so recently i
actually went to i don't know familiar
you are with british politics but i
recently traveled up to westminster
where i did an in-person sit-down
interview with the the former health
secretary to the uk matt hancock um
and you know that was a convert you know
this is a man who was
instrumental in the uk lockdowns uh the
vaccination program
and he's been a part of the the tory
cabinet for years now
um and he was recently dismissed for
some um for some scandal but i had that
conversation i remember we we went up we
were going to parliament it was all
quite exciting
i was really excited and felt optimistic
i had the chat and then it was quite a
long drive back home to wales where i'm
from
and i remember we had almost saw this
sort of adrenaline dump where i just the
conversation left me feeling a bit a bit
sad a bit drained
and
i was thinking ah that wasn't really
what i thought it was gonna do for me on
a personal level and then a day later i
had a completely different type of
interview i i interviewed neil degrasse
tyson about you know
space and astronomy and i remember
coming away from that and i felt the
opposite i felt energized i felt
you know i felt good and so my question
would be is it possible to be
immersed in politics and be truly happy
at the same time
as uh as an observer or as a participant
as an observer
oh oh yeah i yes i think so i think so i
mean again i think if you have the right
mix of things you're paying attention to
if you are uh i mean one of the things i
try to do is
i i try to read a lot and usually the
first thing i do in the morning is i
will read if i have some free time
during the day i will read in the
evenings i will read and because i'm not
reading any politics i'm reading science
i'm reading history i'm reading
narrative nonfiction and business books
and all these different things
it's much easier to kind of have a mix
of things swirling around in your head i
know friends who get so sucked in to a
particular news story it completely
takes over and it's natural to be
pessimistic in that sense but i do think
there are things to be optimistic about
and what's interesting about your
example is
one of the things i would like to see in
american politics and it may apply
elsewhere as well is folks from more
diverse backgrounds getting involved in
politics the cynical perspective would
be if neil degrasse tyson became an
elected official he would become just
like them right
my view is different which is if we had
more people with neil degrasse tyson's
background in politics it would actually
dramatically improve things you know one
example is there's a congressman in the
u.s named jamie raskin
who is from maryland he's truly
like a progressive activist if you go
and you look at his record when he was
in the maryland state house and etc this
is a guy who has achieved meaningful
change and has proposed meaningful bills
he's really done things that are helping
people rather than just being kind of in
this bogged down obstructionist
perspective so i think there's a there's
a lot there but i do think it's possible
to follow what's going on in the world
and to remain optimistic um yeah
just on that thread there of of my story
of parliament obviously recently in the
uk our prime minister boris johnson has
been caught up in quite a lot of scandal
i mean it's it's undeniable now that
there is evidence that
you know you attended many uh parties
that were technically illegal at the
time
and you feel as though
that would really be enough for him to
be removed from that position of you
know the person making these laws and
then actively
breaking them quite you know in in such
a manner but that just
seems to be swept under the rug and we
move on to the next thing and this
why is it that these things can go
unpunished why do these things tend to
just slip through and
is there any hope anymore that something
like that could actually have
repercussions or are we just sort of
powerless in that regard
well it only will have repercussions if
the people truly care now what is the
people well the people could be a number
of different things it could be
the institutions put in place to hold
others accountable it could be voters in
saying well this is over the line but
there's been this normalization of
things that in the past would be just
flatly unacceptable i mean if you go
back here in the united states to
the donald trump primary of 2016
when this access hollywood tape came out
where donald trump was recorded saying
you know when you're famous you can do
whatever you want you can grab them by
the you-know-what the initial reaction
from many was this is it this is over
but then the voters didn't care and if
there's no one
determined to hold you accountable then
it doesn't really matter you know we had
similar things here in the united states
where republicans and democrats alike
including you know you had entire states
disregarding what were supposed to be
the protocols you had individual elected
officials like nancy pelosi the speaker
of the house getting some haircut when
you weren't supposed to go get a haircut
i don't know or gavin newsom the
governor of california having a similar
party i think at an expensive restaurant
you know it's uh at
things have changed so much where
events that previously would be sort of
one's death now no longer are and it's
really just a reflection of the of the
circumstances with trump i mean it was
every three days
there was what in the past would be a
major scandal you know but drawing on a
weather map with a sharpie and saying
this is the real path of the hurricane
and then going to puerto rico after a
hurricane and shooting rolls of paper
towels you know blithely like
basketballs
and then uh flushing documents down the
toilet and then stealing documents and
then you know i mean any one of these
things at some point would have would
have ended your political career but if
there's no one willing or determined to
hold you accountable it doesn't really
matter
so as i mentioned at the top this is a
personal development podcast and and how
i managed to get into these
conversations of politics especially
going back a year ago where i did a few
of them
i i don't really know but what i have
noticed is this seems to be a lot of
money in politics right there's a lot of
clicks in politics
i could put out an episode with you know
a an oxford professor on philosophy and
it'll it'll do okay but then i'll do a
political episode with all these buzz
and these themes in it off the charts
and i know from my own experience and
i'll hold my hands up i i'm not being
perfect i've almost thought sometimes of
certain videos i could put out that i
know would do well but
and there are a lot of episodes i've
recorded that i've never released
because i know they would do well but i
just don't feel right putting them out
oh boy i hope this isn't one of them
but what i'm getting to is this on one
of the things i noticed there seems to
be a lot of money and this is why i
think that we see all these great
academics being drawn into this game of
you won't believe what awoke i've done
now like how could the look i woke this
is this seems to be so much
money clicks viral
opportunity in that why is this
you won't believe what the woke of them
why is that such a
a big money maker that i i seem to have
noticed
well you'd have to ask either the people
producing or watching the anti-woke
stuff i'm in neither camp so it's hard
for me to speak to that what i will say
is
there are areas that are much more
click-worthy like for example this amber
heard johnny depp trial in the united
states which
it's it's overwhelmingly non-political
uh streamers and audiences that are
watching and producing it i've done a
little bit of streaming of it when i
kind of am curious as to what's going on
but the audience that that has garnered
is orders of magnitude bigger than any
of the of the political stuff so i think
there's still way bigger areas if you
know low-hanging fruit so to speak
uh but i do think that
a lot of the framing without being as
familiar with the anti-woke content as
as maybe you are
i do think that any time that you can
frame an issue as
these people are doing something
terrible that's inherently interesting
to different factions and sometimes
these people really are doing something
terrible and sometimes it's not so
terrible and we all do that sort of
content because people do do bad things
in in the world and so covering that is
legitimate um but i don't think it's
anything i mean salacious stuff does
well generally i don't think it's just
in the online politics space
yeah and for me i think it's it's quite
sad sometimes when i see
you know
really
great professors who have a lot of value
to give in this subject
maybe a psychology psychiatry philosophy
that seem to just come over and get
drawn into this game of politics where
i'm not sure what the motivation is
maybe it does work then maybe they
realize that there's a
a different avenue in there i don't know
but it does make me sad sometimes when
we see
what i consider to be great minds in
their own field and we're just bogging
them down or they bog themselves down
with these questions that really have no
meaning
yeah i'd be curious who you're thinking
of i i mean there's a lot of people i
think that have have given that a shot
and to different degrees of success for
sure
but uh it's certainly a phenomenon that
i i agree in agreement is a real one
yeah i'm for sure and you know i don't
want to name names
too much because you know some of these
people i know but i'll give you one
example i i
when i was younger i read um
maps of meaning by jordan peterson and i
thought that was great content for what
it was and i really do enjoy jordan
peterson's lectures you know on
psychology on on meaning is sort of
biblical series that you can take value
out of not from a religious point of
view for myself but there is value in it
i've read 12 rules for life i've read
beyond order and i i do enjoy his
lectures but
sometimes i'll go on twitter and i'll
i'll maybe see jordan you know reply to
something about a certain topic and i'll
think
come on you know like i i'm guessing you
weren't thrilled with his opinion of how
attractive a heavier soup um swimsuit
model was on the cover of sports
illustrator you didn't necessarily think
that was his peak i think is what i'm
hearing from you
yeah like that didn't really
that didn't really do much for me i
remember i remember when i when i saw
her and i thought
what
what sort of disappointed me about that
more so than anything was that
no one really
asked the question there wasn't
it wasn't right it was people weren't
clamoring for jordan's opinion about
that
yeah and it wasn't there it wasn't
it wasn't retweeting something that said
wow look how beautiful this woman is it
was literally i think just a photo um
that really didn't you know maybe didn't
need to be commented on or no one asked
the question and that is it because it
is a shame because i love you know i
have a lot of respect for for jordan and
his i've had his wife tammy peterson on
this podcast and it was an incredible
conversation we talked about
meaning we talked about all these all
these values and it was and that was one
of my favorite episodes i've ever done
there's no politics in it but i really
enjoyed it and
yeah it is sad when you see what i
consider to be great minds get drawn
into this game of politics well i i
agree with you about the example you
know we have different perspectives
about peterson which are neither here
nor there but yeah no i agree with you
there are it's it's happening a lot that
folks are sort of tainting their own um
public perception or public standing by
jumping into issues where maybe we
didn't need to know their opinions
that's absolutely fair
yeah and
you know another to keep sort of
going out certain names and i'm
certainly not i don't know i'm gonna go
with anyone right now but
i think a big one for me as well um over
the last few years if you go back to
myself a young guy in university i used
to really love the joe rogan experience
i would tune in for personal development
mindset
um
health and fitness all these topics and
i wouldn't miss an episode when i was in
university i would watch every hour of
every episode and i got a lot of value
and i and there are certain things that
stay with me now that i learned through
that podcast but i couldn't probably
tell you the last time i listened to an
episode of joe rogan because
sometimes i'll tune in and i'll think
you know it's this political matter
again that i don't really get much
information from there's not much
substance to it
and it
i don't know
when sort of rogan became the the
authority on on
everything that is politics and and
health
but yeah it is sad to see that that
happening and
a lot of people consider sort of joe
rogan to be one of the most important
figures of our time right now i wonder
what
your opinion on that would be
well i i you know i know joe a little
bit i've been on his program twice i
agree with you that some of the most
interesting interviews i've ever seen
have happened on rogan's program uh
without without a doubt and um
uh you know i've
one of one example is when he had
michael pollan on after michael pollan
wrote uh this is your brain on plants
which is a fascinating fascinating book
that's an incredible that's really an
incredible conversation and sort of the
curiosity that rogan brings to it and
and uh i mean it's just fantastic it's
it's unbridled it's fantastic no caveats
you know
and then all the covet stuff and then
some of the trans stuff and all these
different things where it's like
i i it has been disappointing and i have
not shied away from criticizing that the
rogan podcast when it when i feel it
deserves criticism it's a very very
mixed bag for sure
for sure for sure and um just as we
start to to wind down
get into some other questions before we
go the people of when i mentioned on our
newsletter you were coming on that these
were topics that were given to me
um let's see if i can find a few here
there was a tweet i actually enjoyed
that i'll set this one up you said that
um they say not to politicize mass
shootings but also don't want them
studied as a public health matter in
what category should match mass
shootings exist and this was one of the
topics that
we were asked to ask you about is this
sort of school shoot in gun control and
you touched on earlier where you say a
lot of people think that we need more
prey
well
i think the main argument from the other
side would be that there needs to be
more gun control um
i'm maybe not going to ask you your
opinion on that so much but what other
areas do you think
that we could look at to combat
situations like this because
i you know i don't wanna
say that it is the answer but i'm from
the uk i can't really name you a mass
shooting we that we've ever had we
probably have had a few but certainly
none that stick out in my mind and this
is a country where it's very illegal to
own a gun
well listen um
the united states
of uh
western developed nations has the most
guns and the highest rate of death from
mass shooting so you that's that's
correlation okay you still have to look
at causation
uh i am more than willing to look at
other aspects of this issue so for
example when in the last few weeks the
right has been saying
this is exclusively an issue of mental
health only nuts would do things like
this well it's it's it's not exclusively
that but
if this is a factor and i can see that
to some degree there is something
mentally going on with many of the
people willing to do this although the
buffalo manifesto was quite cogent
fascism i will say yeah but but putting
that aside if we want to deal with the
mental health aspect i'm all for it but
what that would mean is
required mental health screenings
initially and periodically for you to
have a firearm
actually funding better access to mental
health services which many republicans
who say it's a mental health issue have
voted against funding and number three
generally speaking if there's so much
problem with mental illness we should
try to reduce the ease with which
mentally ill people can obtain firearms
so i have no problem dealing with the
mental health aspect prayer i don't
think is a factor you know now there's a
lot of talk about doors and schools the
problem isn't guns but it's how many
doors the school building has ted cruz
and others have talked about it it's
it's all it almost sounds hysterical to
hear it
i'm fine thinking about
the security setup in and around schools
that's great
most most of the suggestions are either
impractical and or also wouldn't apply
to other places where we've seen
shootings including movie theaters
um and grocery stores recently etc so
but i'm not saying do not talk about
school security it's fine to talk about
school security arming teachers seems
crazy
uh so for me i think this is you know
there are some maybe on the left who say
we shouldn't even talk about any of
those things i'm fine talking about
those things in proportion to the degree
to which i think they're a problem
but the guns have to be the starting
point for the conversation and i put out
a list of 10 different things i would do
specifically on gun safety without
eliminating the second amendment we have
a second amendment you can keep it but i
think that that's where you have to
start
yeah and again i'll hold my hands up i
don't really know much about gun control
in the usa other than from i'm from i
get on on tv but maybe you could
enlighten me if i was an american
citizen and i wanted to get a hold of a
gun how easy would it be for me to do
that
it depends on the state and it depends
on um
where you want to obtain the firearm and
so there's no way that i could give you
the full patchwork of laws but there are
states which have so-called
constitutional carry which means
you don't need a permit or training you
can just basically have a firearm there
are differences between there's kind of
sometimes three layers of
the ability to purchase a firearm but
you can't carry it with you
concealed carry
um and uh i forget what the other not
con not concealed carry exposed carry i
know that there's another word for it
visibly carrying firearms um depending
on the states sometimes there is
reciprocity on the permits and sometimes
there is not
depending on where you go and if you
obtain a firearm from someone you
personally know there might or might not
be a background check only 22 states and
washington dc require a background check
so it's a patchwork of different laws
it would be shockingly easy for you to
get a firearm generally speaking
i guess the big problem so to speak
would be how if it is so easy and so
many people own them how would you even
begin to
to recall them
yeah well this is a big thing where
anytime you want to talk about
restrictions
people start saying you're confiscating
guns like a nazi right and and the truth
is
you would put in place a bunch of gun
safety regulations
you would probably offer some buybacks
where people are paid for firearms that
are no longer in compliance that they
willingly turn in and then there would
be some time period after which having
certain firearms would would become
illegal i mean it it all has to be done
thoughtfully and coherently
and unfortunately
it's so polarized that it's hard to
really even have these conversations
well thank you for answering and that's
very complex question and the other
topic we were asked most about was again
we we talked about these these great
minds becoming involved in the world of
politics
obviously there's this elon musk by in
buying twitter um which is you can't
really escape it in the news a lot of
people saying that it is a triumphant
event for free speech
where do you weigh in on on elon musk
and his
you know his uh pursuit of buy into her
well
when the possibility of him buying
twitter was first announced i was very
skeptical that it would happen and it
does now seem like it's not going to
happen you know he says that the
transaction is on hold he said a couple
weeks ago because of his
lack of belief about the number of fake
users
some are saying that it's just a cop out
that he never intended to buy it i don't
know but i was always skeptical that he
was really going to buy twitter now
about elon musk
i have a sort of um
i don't want to call it an agnostic view
on elon musk but i certainly have a view
that is very much in the gray area
i
was a relatively early investor in tesla
i mean i think i first bought stock like
eight years ago
and i drive a tesla and i think that
they're great vehicles and that the
degree to which he has moved forward
electric vehicle technology
is absolutely to be applauded without
question betting against elon musk on a
business level seems to be a bad bet
historically speaking on the one hand on
the other hand
he's just another person you know in the
same way that i don't really love the
cult of personality around elected
officials be it whoever sometimes they
say things that i agree with or disagree
with sometimes they say bone-headed
things whatever it's kind of similar to
me with elon musk i think he's had a lot
of bad takes that he's tweeted about
when when he he tweeted this meme whose
main point was that the left has become
extreme recently but the right hasn't
moved i think it's just flat out wrong
and it's sort of beyond the scope of
this answer to delve into that in detail
i just think he's wrong about that that
doesn't mean that tesla hasn't moved
forward electric vehicle technology
dramatically so it i think the black and
white view about musk i think he says a
lot of dumb things as you said earlier
he wades into conversations i'm not even
curious what elon musk thinks about a
lot of these things and at the same time
we could we can recognize that some of
his businesses have done really
important things
well that's really refreshing to hear
because like i mentioned earlier about
you know you you don't have to agree or
disagree with everything that one person
says to be you know
for that to be your opinion on the
person you know i mentioned
jordan peterson i am sure
because you know we have listeners and
subscribers who came over to this
podcast from
my episode with with tammy peterson that
did really well and i'm sure they're
gonna maybe hear one of two of the
things i've said today and they're gonna
come at me and maybe unsubscribe for it
that doesn't mean that i'm not a fan of
of jordan peterson for all the things
that sort of brought me to the dance i
still can go back and enjoy that book
and i do have a ticket to one of his
lectures in the uk
and
just because i don't agree with his
opinion on on politics or or woke that
doesn't mean that i can't appreciate
other other parts of him and and his
mind so i'm i am really glad that you
mentioned that about elon musk because i
think that's important for for people to
remember before they maybe come for us
yeah i mean listen i expect there uh
having looked through some of the
interviews you've done and some of the
comments i expect that there will be
lots of people who will very much
disagree with me uh i would be shocked
if people don't comment that uh you know
how could you how couldn't you tell that
david was being disingenuous and all
these different it's every interview i
do right i mean so that's fine uh while
i disagree with you about your opinion
about the value of some of peterson's
stuff i agree very much with the concept
that there's no there's no perfect match
with any one particular person's views
and so for me one of the things that
does bum me out is when some of our like
paid supporters on our membership
program will write to me and they'll say
david you know i've been with you for
years
but i just really disagree with you
about you know whether a hot dog is a
sandwich just to pick something very
innocuous and so i'm i'm withdrawing my
support financially and what bums me out
about that is
my
expectation is never that any two people
will agree about everything at some
point you will find disagreement but i i
don't want to let the sort of sometimes
the term the narcissism of small
differences is used cloud that maybe you
believe that what i do is valuable in
that i'm a non-corporate source of
commentary
uncontrolled by you know a team of
editors and all these different things
and we mostly agree
and that's pretty good
does one disagreement change that if the
one disagreement was me having some
horribly racist view i would i would
actually understand that because that's
so antithetical to what so many people
believe i would get that but on
something relatively more benign i think
it's reasonable that we're never always
going to agree
yeah i really appreciate that you know
as this conversation has gone along
there's been you know things that i've
said that you've disagreed with and
probably vice versa but
you know what we're still at the end of
this conversation i think it's been
conducted in a really friendly manner i
think you're a great guy i can see that
myself and we're able to have a
conversation and i thoroughly enjoyed it
and i think that's important for people
to understand i agree i agree and again
i understand when people will say
david you're not friends with any raging
anti-semites for a reason and i would
say that's true that's true but i'm
friends with lots of people with a
different opinion about what the top tax
rate would be and we have to be able to
kind of draw distinctions about
differences versus other differences
so two questions quick questions that we
end every interview i ask every single
guest the first one are there any books
that have had a massive impact on your
life up to this point
oh you know i read so much it's sort of
like what's your favorite movie to
someone who's a film connoisseur it's
it's so difficult to say
uh but wow that it it's just very very
tough i mean i'm reading i think the
what i would say is
what has added the most value
is reading lots of different types of
books and so when it comes to fiction
i'm reading sci-fi
and i'm reading classics and i'm re you
know because everything does something
different for me when it comes to
non-fiction i'm reading you know daniel
kahneman's behavioral economics i'm
reading john krakauer's narrative
nonfiction
into the air and into into uh you know
with the the two i forget into the wild
i'm reading um
i think the the best recommendation is
to be taking in a lot of very different
types of books is the best
recommendation i'm not big on political
memoirs me because i'm in politics all
the time so i just i don't read any
political memoirs i don't care about
them uh and i don't do any sell
self-help stuff either
but beyond that it's just a
large breadth of content is the best
thing i can say
so the final question for david pakman
right now what makes life worth living
well i am so curious about the future
that for me i i'm always wondering
what is today going to get to
next week next month next year i mean i
just have an unending curiosity about
what's coming
and what's coming is a result of what's
happening now so i think it would be
that that general idea that right what
happens in the future will depend on
what we are doing right now and so i'm a
part we're all a part of that and
participating i think it's that general
curiosity about the future
fantastic and for our listeners and and
uh people watching right now on youtube
who may not be able to see that big
screen behind you that says the david
pakman show where can our listeners find
you and get from more from you and
connect with you we're on almost every
platform but my website davidpakman.com
links out to everything
amazing well david thank you so much for
your time today and coming on i've
really enjoyed it and i believe it to be
a really important conversation and one
that i very much appreciate it's been a
pleasure thank you for having me